NOW IT'S TIME TO
PLAY FRIGHTS, CAMERA, ACTION.
A CANADIAN HAUNTED HOUSE CALLED
THE NIGHTMARES FEAR FACTORY HAS
BEEN RECORDING PEOPLE'S
REACTIONS BY HIDDEN CAMERA AND
SHARING THEM WITH THE WORLD, UH,
ON THEIR FLICKR PAGE.
SO I'M GONNA SHOW YOU A PICTURE
FROM SAID FLICKR PAGE AND FOR
250 POINTS, I WANT YOU TO TELL
ME WHAT YOU THINK THEY'RE SO
AFRAID OF, OKAY?
FIRST ONE-- THESE JERSEY BOYS.
(BELL DINGS)
THESE JERSEY BOYS.
YES, BRIAN.
>> SOMEONE TOLD THEM JOVI'S
REALLY FROM PHILLY.
>> HARDWICK: OH, SHIT, OH.
>> NO FUCKIN' WAY!
>> HARDWICK: NO WAY!
>> WHAT THE FUCK, JOVI?
>> HARDWICK: POINTS FOR POSEHN.
AISHA.
>> UH, THEIR HOMEY AND DRANK
ALL THE FOUR LOKO.
>> HARDWICK: YEAH, POINTS.
AND HE'S NOT DOING WELL.
>> NO, HE'S NOT FEELING GOOD.
>> HARDWICK: STEVE.
>> JOB APPLICATIONS.
>> HARDWICK: POINTS.
>> NO!
NEXT ONE-- LOOK AT THESE SARAH
PALINS...
(BELL DINGS)
POSEHN?
>> THEY JUST FOUND OUT THAT NICE
ELLEN IS A LESBIAN.
>> HARDWICK: OH, NICE, POINTS.
YEAH.
POINTS.
AISHA.
>> WELL, THEY JUST FOUND OUT THE
PRESIDENT'S BLACK.
>> HARDWICK: WHAT?
JUST NOW?
>> JUST NOW.
>> HARDWICK: POINTS.
HOW COME THEY'VE SEEN NO
PICTURES OF HIM?
>> THAT WASN'T A SATURDAY NIGHT
LIVE SKETCH?
>> HARDWICK: POINTS.
ALL RIGHT, NEXT ONE-- THIS
COUPLE.
(BELL DINGS)
YES, AISHA.
>> CHILI'S RAN OUT OF JALAPENO
POPPERS.
>> HARDWICK: POINTS.
BRIAN.
>> THEY FORGOT THAT PATTON
OSWALT WAS LIVE-TWEETING
DOWNTON ABBEY.
>> HARDWICK: THAT MUT BE WHAT IT
WAS.
THEY MISSED THE WHOLE... LIVE
TWEET.
>> THEY LOVE IT.
>> HARDWICK: POINTS.
STEVE.
>> SLEEVES.
>> HARDWICK: OF COURSE, POINTS.
NEXT, HOW ABOUT THESE BFFS?
WHAT ABOUT THESE BFFS?
(BELL DINGS)
HEY, YES... STEVE.
>> SOMEONE SEEING THEIR ANKLES.
>> HARDWICK: BRILLIANT, POINTS.
AISHA.
>> THEY JUST FOUND OUT THEY'RE
GETTING A THIRD SISTER-WIFE.
>> HARDWICK: POINTS.
OH, SHIT, YEAH.
POINTS FOR THAT.
BRIAN.
>> UH, LORNE MICHAELS CUT THE
AMISH GOLLUM SKETCH.
>> HARDWICK: VERY INSIDE, BUT
VERY POINTSY.
POINTS.
>> PRECIOUS.
>> HARDWICK: LAST ONE-- THESE
GUYS, THESE GUYS.
(BELL DINGS)
I DON'T KNOW, THIS GUY DOESN'T
EVEN REALLY LOOK AFRAID, HE'S
JUST...
STEVE.
>> MIATA THIEVES.
>> HARDWICK: POINTS.
BRIAN.
>> UH, KATHY GRIFFIN CANCELLED
HER BOOK SIGNING.
>> HARDWICK: JESUS. OH, MY GOD.
POINTS.
AISHA.
>> VAGINAS!
>> HARDWICK: POINTS.